more people weighed in on the Brent
Hollywood Squares controversy some
people agree with me a lot of people
thought I was being a dick I really
didn't think I was I really did and I'm
not looking a forced print to do
anything I just honestly was trying to
understand the lines drawn in the
swinging community so we're planning
Hollywood Squares for Christmas
somebody has a great idea Brent's wife
Caitlyn would be the center square
except she would be a couple with the
jackhammer I go that's a brilliant idea
and what happened Brent blew a [ __ ] fit
really you went to California right
Kaitlyn [ __ ] the jackhammer in your
head
correct and having him on Hollywood
Squares with her is crossing the line
way over the line don't you think
jackhammer [ __ ] Caitlyn in your bed
is over the line no she likes to [ __ ]
and move on by the way Ronny seems to
think and I guess I should bring this
into the conversation he thinks you're
in big trouble okay LeBron what do you
what do you say him nothing not big
trouble I think he's starting to crack a
little bit yeah I think I think he
opened the door that he can't close now
I'm not looking to close any door wrong
yeah but I don't tell everyone your
theory Ron it's not really a theory it's
just that I think you opened up this
door where you exposed your whole life
on the air of sex and what you guys do
and now it's coming back to bite us a
little bit nothing's biting me in the
ass though how was it biting me my nails
I'm looking at you when you walk out of
this studio after what goes on in here
you're like a beaten man well it's it's
emotionally draining and it's highly
emotional to be in here but I'm not
beaten everything's great if
everything's great if you didn't open
that door this never would have happened
well you think that I've been doing this
a quarter of over a quarter of a century
Ronny I know what opening this door
meant I know where these things go you
opened up Pandora's box and now we see
Caitlyn's meat curtains it's that simple
you think he's cracking up despite all
this on a bravado all his cons I'm sorry
it's got to get to him because you see
him in the hall I see him in the hall he
walks around with his head down right
walked around with my head I know that
Brent but it's it's more now than ever
like even in LA man you really lost it
you can't tell me you didn't okay it is
in a dark place in a very dark place my
theory is men called jackhammer
generally you don't put them around your
wife period I don't kiss your swinger or
not no I saw pictures dude you don't put
away Chris Wilding said he looked like
Thanos and he wasn't far off [ __ ] guy
was yacht Omid he's a big of course he's
hot with a big guy a guy called
jackhammer I'm like you know it okay I'm
a swinger but I'm drawing the line at
that didn't aim jackhammer no one named
jackhammer is [ __ ] my wife but I do
want to give you this like because
because this whole LA you know New York
experiment with us doing stuff apart
yeah it kind of weirded us out we thank
you and we kind of didn't like it right
Ronnie is right either one of us
so we've decided we're gonna do stuff
together cuz this is a thing that we do
together and we can I think I went too
far I agree yeah I got out of control it
was an experiment that we've decided to
let the audience in on right in I think
that you're right would move that we
went too far yeah it's not a stupid move
when you experiment you try things we're
figuring out what it is that we like all
right and I think that you were right
that we went too far yes but I still
think she enjoyed it more than he did
that no you do but then me come in but
that's not exactly that's not true
either I mean you can think that but
it's just not true it's just by
listening to it I'm just giving it a pin
right but when she was describing her
[ __ ] and getting pounded yes and that I
mean she was on fire
well anyway I'm still keeping my fingers
crossed on E and I'm hoping that jack
hammer shows up in the Senate square but
yesterday did that change your mind at
all no I'm like a gentleman oh he is
most guys in the swingers lifestyle are
that way right most guys are very calm
and gentlemanly like that you have to be
right it has nothing it's not personal
it's this is a rule in our marriage that
we're not going to break alright fair
enough very poor those of you hope
you're right Ronnie I said I hope you're
right I am right
you